pour tout comprendre ce soir on reçoit
clément gignac économiste en chef de
l'industrielle alliance on soit clément
gignac et luc godbout titulaire de la
chaire de recherche en fiscalité et en
finances publiques de l'université de
sherbrooke le bonsoir bonsoir
alors on va tenter de bien comprendre
tout ce qui se passe clément d'abord est
ce que le soutien annoncé par le
gouvernement fédéral aujourd'hui
suffisants pour aider les travailleurs
les ménages les entreprises
la réponse est non mais c'est déjà un
premier pas dans la bonne direction
clairement parce que ces mêmes précédent
look et envisagez vous la peine une
semaine
rappelant quand on parle de 27 milliards
d'injection pour venir en aide aux
travailleurs qui se retrouvent sans
emploi pour qu'ils puissent faire leur
épicerie ou de crédit d'impôts de tps
que vous pouvez nous expliquer les décès
clairement on y voit en priorité le
personnel or les besoins essentiels
aussi les gens ont besoin de payer les
hypothèques six autres perdent leur
emploi les banques vont montrer de la
souplesse ils faisaient des jo mais le
cei comme un peu et sioniste mais
clairement on va avoir des mesures d'
autres mesures annoncées comptait
beaucoup plus substantiel a vite fait
état de toutes les essences mais qui se
passe donc en ayant utilisé l'expression
wade vortex on s'occupe plus du déficit
on veut éviter une dépression calmer
donc clairement il va voir du monde à
encore plus substantielle votre nom
c'est oui la prochaine étape c'est des
mesures de stimulation calmer est ce que
fait bien ciblé lui qu'est ce qu'on
touche bien les gens affectés par la
crise ceux qui perdent leur emploi qui
perdent des contrats qui perdent des
revenus et je crois qu'on couvre à ses
larmes dans le fond on commence par les
travailleurs justement qui sont en
quarantaine
on a aussi un programme pour les
travailleurs qui perdent leur emploi on
a un programme pour les travailleurs qui
volontairement réduisent leurs camps de
travail donc ça déjà en partant via
l'assurance emploi il ya une bonne
couverture et on ajoute de l'aide pour
les moins nantis
via
quiconque reçoit un crédit de tps va
voir son crédit de tps bonifiée on
pourra y revenez et on vise également
plus de manière encore plus large des
familles en général encore une fois tout
familles recevant de la location
canadienne pour enfants doit recevoir
une bonification
donc on recouvre ses larges c'est sûr
que les besoins sont quand même énorme
mais pas de changements à
l'assurance-emploi
mais faut pas y penser
gerald que ainsi que toutes les
provinces qui est génial avec les formes
et c'est comme ça pensez aux employés le
des fonctions publiques que peut-être
qu'ils ont pas voulu prendre de chance
parce que 2,6 commencé à changer les
ratios petit sort on veut pas de
l'informatique nous tombe là et on fait
des chèques
ceux-ci 5 millions les adresses des gens
on aboie parce que monter le ratio de 55
à 90 % comme moi je vends s'arrêter un
peu compliquée dont on niveau que
l'échec
puis ça va pas l'échec monte plus gros
et ça va durer pour plus longtemps parce
que c'est une vérité six mois ce soit
six mois alors le que les locations de
soins d'urgence d'abord et avant tout
décrivez ce que c'est alors la location
de soins d'urgence donc c'est un peu
comme le gouvernement du québec lève
annoncé plus tôt cette semaine donc
c'est pour les travailleurs qui doivent
rester à la maison mais qui n'ont pas
accès à un congé de maladie de la part
de l'employeur qui ont pas accès de
l'assurance emploi etc les gens malades
les gens en quarantaine
c'est les gens qui s'isolent
volontairement pour s'occuper donc d'un
parent ou d'un enfant alors le programme
on parle de 900 $ par deux semaines ou
de 450 $ par semaine et on parle d'une
main d'un maximum de 15 semaines
donc c'est quand même un programme
nouveau à lui seul on parle de 10
milliards de dollars et il s'est quand
même c'est ça c'est quand même une cause
une grosse annonce de la journée donc ça
c'est pour les gens en isolement ou
malades essentiellement il ya
l'allocation de soutien d'urgence pour
les gens qui perdent leur emploi les
travailleurs autonomes
we dance que dans ce cas là c'est ça sa
couvée gagnent donc ce programme lancé
c'est les gens qui auraient pas été
couverts par l'assurance emploi on
élargit donc le programme donc les
travailleurs autonomes deviennent
deviennent admissibles à ce programme de
de soutien
d'urgence et on parle on parle
d'appliquer les mêmes paramètres là en
terme d'aidé en termes de couverture que
l'assurance emploi actuel wilson gens
pourraient ressembler aussi à 450
dollars par semaine
ça promet mes pieds techniquement on
peut entrevoir un peu plus la baisse de
du côté de l'assurance santé - vous
alliez vous inspirer de du mets toi si
un défaut de prudence si vous si vous
voyez dans vos archives dans les
prochains jours on s'est inspiré de 2003
pour couvrir plus large parce qu'on
avait eu un peu la même situation devant
trois pilotes avaient couvert des gens
qu'on coupe un armement sur ne sais pas
quoi
donc il y avait déjà utilisé cette
technique les l'ont fait je m'en fais
pas été quinze semaines par ceux ci se
fait pas savoir l'egypte au moins 71 ne
sais pas combien de temps en boîte mais
en 41 mais la bonification du crédit de
tps
alors le crédit de tps le crédit est
doublé alors on parle pour mettre une
personne seule qui aurait reçu 300
dollars va donc pouvoir recevoir sur une
base annuelle 6 ans mais se trouve afin
de leur lot de kaki est majoré va
arriver dans le chèque du mois de mai et
donc c'est 300 $ par adulte et ses 150 $
par enfant pour le mois inscire ou pour
tous les mois à venir
c'est pour le mois de mai seulement
l'avion ce qui a été fait ces doubles et
puis on verse en versant au mois de mai
au mois de mai seulement donc c'est
pourrait donner le plus rapidement
possible de l'argent aux ménages
alors si on parle dans le cas d'une
famille monoparentale 750 dollars qu'ils
vont recevoir de plus et pourtant le
code d'une d'une famille serait
admissible
ça peut aller ça peut aller à 900
dollars le d'un code 1 coupe c'est quoi
imposable c'est les crédits de tps là
aucune bonification de la location
canadienne pour enfants 300 dollars de
plus au mois de mai par enfant donc
encore une fois c'est 300 $ de plus par
enfant
alors je vous donne un exemple si on a
une
un couple avec deux enfants mais avec un
revenu à céder leurs revenus de 100
mille dollars
naturellement il y aurait pas droit aux
crédits de tps mais s'ils ont deux
enfants il y aurait 600 $ de plus en
allocation canadienne pour enfants donc
en mai au lieu de recevoir 4 186 dollars
ils recevraient 1086 de lancer quand
même une bonification aux problèmes aux
jardins pub plus élevés qui sont
significatifs
clément et pour les pme les entreprises
une nouvelle subvention salariale aux
entreprises
cette intéressante oui entre nous sera
insuffisant l'ordre de 10% de la masse
salariale dans ce cas là c'est pour une
avance de fonds c'est vraiment une
subvention jusqu'à concurrence de 25
milles ce qu'il restera de petit
entrepreneur on veut réunir en aide
les oc et des caisses vont se monter
très flexible au niveau des obligations
financières qui ont les approvisionner
professionnels sont reportés donc c'est
un premier pas dans la bonne direction
puis pour revenir à ce que le bnc
certains pourraient être des supposés
ouais mais là c'est juste un mois faut
pas s'en faire avec ce c'est à dire tant
sont longtemps que l'économie sera pas
revenue à la normale
s'ils savent à quoi ça va être un double
avec sedan cette année des versus
produits qui vont faire ça tous les mois
pendant ce mois ci dans le fond dans
trois mois pour une raison quelconque
que les mains on commence à voir comme
la chine dirigeant peut pas tourner au
travail d'encerclement vous bougez pas
l'udc non plus vous restez l'on se
retrouve dans un instant après la pause
avec la suite des explications